okay let's get started so today we're
going to be covering uh a fun
fun topic because a lot of what we'll be
covering is stuff that's extremely
recent
now
topic-wise really the question that
we're going to be focusing on
for the lecture today is
how should we be defining tasks
for good metal learning performance
we've talked a lot about different metal
learning algorithms and we've talked
about one way to construct tasks we've
also looked at some case studies
but
in this lecture we're going to talk
about some of the different failure
modes that can come up um or some of the
situations where maybe it's pretty hard
to confront tasks and some of the things
that you might be able to do in those
situations
so
in particular the plan for today is to
very briefly
recap the three different metal learning
approaches that we've talked about as
well as the
kind of ways to confront tasks that
we've talked about then we're going to
talk about memorization in metal
learning and when it arises a potential
solution to that and then lastly we'll
talk about metal learning when you don't
have any tasks that are provided and
ways in which the algorithm might be
able to automatically come up with tasks
that it should solve in a way that can
allow it to still be able to quickly
adapt to human defined downstream tasks
as i mentioned these topics are really
new uh they're really at the bleeding
edge of research and so just as a
disclaimer or a warning uh potentially a
lot of things that we're gonna be
covering today
uh are
really at the cusp of of what we know
and what we've experimented with and so
i encourage you to ask questions
but for some of those questions i may
not know the answer
they may be still open problems and open
questions in the field
with that said the goals by the end of
the lecture is to help you understand
how when when memorization in middle
learning they occur and understanding
techniques for constructing tasks
automatically
okay so let's get started
so first let's recap the different
approaches that we talked about so
uh i think a couple weeks ago at this
point we talked about black box metal
learning where you have some neural
network
f that takes his input a data also takes
input a new data point and makes a
prediction for that new data point
so the key idea is to kind of
parameterize a learner as a neural
network
this approach is very expressive but
it's also a very challenging
optimization problem
we also talked about optimization-based
meta-learning algorithms which instead
of using a neural network to parametrize
the learner that use an optimization
process and any free parameters of that
optimization process like
the initial parameters or like the inner
learning rate can be
metal earned
uh so the key idea is to kind of
essentially embed this optimization
inside the learning process and optimize
end to end with respect to those
parameters
and this is what you'll be implementing
as part of homework 2 that came out
today
the benefit of this is that you have the
structure of optimization embedded into
the meta learning process the downside
is that it typically requires a
second-order optimization which can be a
bit more
heavy or
computationally intensive uh the good
news though is that
various deep learning libraries that we
have can typically handle
the
the more arduous parts of the second
order optimization for you
and then lastly last week we also talked
about a third class of metal learning
algorithms which i referred to as
non-parametric metal learning algorithms
and the way that these learning
algorithms approach the problem
is they first embed the test example and
all of your training examples
and then they do some sort of nearest
neighbor by comparing your test
embedding to all of the training
embeddings find the one that's the most
similar such as this one right here
and use that to predict the
corresponding label
so really the key idea here is to use a
non-parametric learner which is
basically everything shown in green here
with
a parametric embedding or distance
function which are each of the arrows
shown in blue
for example the non-parametric learner
may be something like k nearest
neighbors to examples or prototypes and
then the parametric embedding is what
the metal learner is learning in order
to make this dom parametric learner
successful with only a few examples
the benefits of this is that it's easy
to optimize and it's computationally
very fast this is entirely a
feed-forward process
the downside is that it so far at least
has been largely restricted to
classification problems
okay so that's kind of a brief recap of
the three middle learning approaches
that we've talked about
uh and then we've also talked about
different ways to construct tasks
so
one of the canonical ways to construct
tasks is to use labeled images from
previous classes in order to allow you
to solve n-way classification problems
with this small number of examples but
we also looked at case studies that
allow you to adapt to regional
differences using labeled label data
from other regions and also
things like future automation learning
where you use demonstrations for
previous tasks
the essence here though is that you
construct tasks using labeled data from
tasks that are representative of the
kinds of tasks that you'll be seeing at
test time
okay so that's a brief recap now let's
talk a bit about
some challenges that come up when we
construct tasks for metal learning
so
for in the example of fuchsia image
classification the tasks that we've
looked at um
look something like this where we
constructed a training set
and some test examples
and we constructed this train set and
test that for basically each of the
tasks
in our training set
now one of the things that we did when
we constructed these tasks is we
randomly assigned labels
to
each class
so for example in this first task
the class of mushroom may get a label of
one whereas in this third task the label
of mushroom might get a label sorry the
class of a mushroom may give get a label
of zero
and so we're randomly assigning
different class labels to image classes
for each task
uh and this means that the tasks are
what i will call mutually exclusive
and what i mean by that is that there
isn't just a single function
that can solve all of these tasks
uh and that's because we're assigning
different labels to different classes so
you don't have a single function that
will both assign a zero to a mushroom
and a one to a mushroom
and likewise for classes like pianos
that also have different labels for
different tasks
okay so one by-product of this
way that we're constructing tasks is
that the algorithm must use the training
data in order to figure out what the
label ordering should be
so it actually has to look at this
training data look at kind of what id
was assigned to mushroom what idea was
assigned to piano and so forth in order
to make accurate predictions
on the test examples
okay so now with this in mind this is
kind of the canonical way that we
construct tasks
what happens if the label order is
consistent
so in particular say that we constructed
tasks like this
where
we always assigned
the label one to mushroom the label two
to this kind of dog
um the label four to carousel the label
one to landscape and so forth
so
based on this i guess
i want to run a little poll to see what
people think
and in particular the question will be
what happens
when the label order is consistent so if
we meditate a model on the tasks like
this with a consistent label ordering
and then test them on new tasks with
held out classes
what do you think
will
happen so i'll launch a poll
and
i'll also give you a minute to think
about it um
and the different options are will do
much better than the shuffle label
ordering slightly better than the
shuffled label learning the same as
before
slightly worse or
much worse
so we have some votes coming in
i mentioned in the chat that he
accidentally did this in homework one
so wait a little bit longer for a few
more votes to trickle in
okay so
we'll end the poll there and i'll share
the results
um so most of you think that it will do
much worse although it's a bit uh
it's not different people think
different things so i'm curious
uh
why people put the answer that they put
so does anyone did anyone say that they
think it perform i guess does anyone
want to share kind of their reasoning
for
why
why they think the answer that they put
you can raise your hand
um uh i put um
my force and the idea there was that if
there is an ordering of classes and if
you use
the model like an lstn then we could see
maybe unit learning features that are
specific to a certain class and then
when they shuffle the ordering at test
time then
they'll do they'll do worse
yeah so the idea there is that
the tasks that will be given at test
time will have a different we'll have
new classes and so we won't necessarily
know the ordering and so
if we learn kind of
things that are specific to these cuts
of these training classes uh with these
with this label ordering maybe it won't
generalize
to that kind of new test task
any other opinions or thoughts that
people want to share
does this make it easier or more
possible to shuffle so for example if we
shuffle i think we can still have all
dogs v2 all
uh sorry i mean i guess the dog is not
two in in the second in t2 but at least
maybe all birds
um
i guess i'm not it's not clear exactly
what you mean by it enables us to
shuffle so if you're training with these
classes that have a consistent label
ordering
during training why do you think that
that makes it easier to shuffle
just trying to understand your reasoning
no in fact maybe i didn't understand
the
yeah yeah very very consistent
all dogs are two and something like that
and so if you see a dog
uh the model is able to predict it too
but it looks more that uh
that something it's more do with the
order of images than what's in the
images maybe
i didn't really understand the question
okay
um and do you want to share your
thoughts
yeah so uh
i put much worse and that's because uh
the model will learn what
so model will learn what class belongs
so
for example in this case
it will learn that a dog is always class
two
so during the training it will do uh it
will always classify it correctly but
for held out classes it won't be able to
generalize
it will be more like a supervised
uh
i guess
yeah it will be more like supervised uh
use case files and mechanical learning
yeah so
just to summarize it it may just learn
to kind of do a supervised regression to
the labels rather than actually learning
to adapt to the data set
um which will
won't if it's more like supervised
learning then it may not be able to
quickly adapt to new examples
and then i see some more hand raised uh
do you want to share your thoughts
yeah yeah i just wanted to ask a
clarifying question so we've mentioned
the order a couple times but in this
case the algorithm doesn't necessarily
or learned order right it's more about
not being able to learn how to learn
instead of learning the supervised
learning tasks is that like a good
summary
yeah so i guess what i meant by ordering
is basically that the
the assignment of class ids to classes
is consistent
um
right right yeah so maybe ordering isn't
quite the
the right way to describe that
yeah okay not that nice thanks
okay
cool and there are a couple more hands
do you want to share something
yeah sure i put much worse i think it
might be problem depending on whether
it's slightly worse or much worse but my
thinking was that if the ordering is
consistent then at meta test time
the model can just
well or during meta training if the if
the labels are consistent
then the model will learn to ignore
the
the label in d train
it no longer needs the y in d train
because it can memorize all of the
classes in the meta training set
yeah exactly so
in some in some ways the the
outline of the lecture sort of maybe
gave it away what the answer was in some
regard
but when you have this consistent
assignment of labels to classes then the
tasks become non-mutually exclusive such
the single function can solve all the
tasks
and this means that your metal learning
metal earned model can simply learn to
classify the inputs irrespective of the
training data that's passed in so you
can basically like completely ignore
the training datasets just learn to
classify
everything in the test sets
per task
and then when you give it a new
training data set it will just it won't
be able to actually process that because
it didn't learn to process
the training sets during medic training
uh and so in particular what can happen
is
if you have a black box model
uh it can simply just ignore all of the
training inputs here
and simply just classify the last input
that's provided to the model
and likewise with an optimization based
model it can also just ignore the data
set and learn a set of initial
parameters
uh that sort of
somehow renders the optimization in the
inner loop
uh kind of irrelevant for example if it
can already predict
all of the examples correctly
just by looking at the image and not by
looking at the labels then the inner
gradient will be zero and that won't
have any impact on
the
network and that will effectively lead
it to ignore the training set also
so
in particular now if you
take if you meditate a model with this
label assignment that's consistent and
then
evaluate it to
a new task with held out classes
with classes like this for example
it doesn't know
what the label should be for each of
these classes it doesn't know what the
assignment should be if it should be 0 1
2 3 or 4 for each of these classes
and because it learned to ignore each of
these training data sets it's also going
to ignore this training data set of the
test task
and it won't be able to effectively make
predictions on the test examples
and if you actually
run mammal on these tasks
you'll get performance that looks like
this so in this case this is a
non-mutually exclusive version of
omniglot where you
apply the same label id to each class
consistently across all the tasks and
you'd see performance drops from
performance roughly in the 90s
to
accuracy numbers that are around 7.8 and
50.7 percent in these different cases
so you see a pretty substantial drop in
performance when you make
the label assignment consistent
now this seems like it shouldn't like
if you think about how you construct
tasks it seems like this like ideally it
shouldn't make this huge of a difference
depending on
like how you assign the labels
so maybe let's kind of dig into this
problem
uh it's asking does this memorization
occur in non-parametric models as well
um so i'll say that it occurs in black
box models
for sure and i'll show some results on
that with regard to non-parametric
models
um
i think that it probably
won't occur because non-parametric
models
basically use the label ordering in a
very specific way
so
um
you basically force the model to use the
labels in a way that looks at similarity
um
and this uh there's kind of no way dude
in the course of this model
there it's probably a lot harder to
completely ignore the training data than
in the other kinds of models because
your predictions have to
um
because you like you literally have to
actually use this similarity in order to
output the correct label
otherwise you have no other way to kind
of directly fast track from x test to y
test other than going through the labels
in your train set
so i think that this problem
i haven't experimented with it in
practice but i'm pretty sure this
problem won't come up for non-parametric
approaches
okay
um
great so this is this seems like a
bit of a problem potentially
um and it's worth mentioning that
potentially for image classification
like we can just shuffle the labels and
we'll still be fine although it is
potentially still perhaps somewhat
disturbing that this this issue comes up
if you don't shuffle the labels
um and maybe it's also not a problem if
we see the same image classes
as training
if we don't see held out image classes
then this model will be fine because it
doesn't actually need to use the
training data
but it is a problem if we want to be
able to adapt with data to new tasks
okay so it looks like there's some
questions and i'll take those questions
now so i think i was gonna assume that
your hand is up from before
uh
not sure if i pronounced that already
do you have a question
uh no actually i was raising him for the
previous question this one
okay
i was still a little confused about why
we're able to say that
um the model ignores the training data
set in mediterrane wouldn't it still
need to look at the meta the train set
in order to correctly classify
the new um test set images
yeah so
basically what happens is i guess so
i'll get into this a little bit later
but it is possible that it will still
learn to pay attention to
this data set here
um but i guess the important thing to
point out is that if piano always has a
label of four then it doesn't need to
figure out it doesn't need to look at
these training examples to tell that
this
that the label should be a four for this
image
um
and
basically if you if there is kind of a
consistent assignment of labels to image
classes then
it can just kind of memorize that
consistent assignment
and
make predictions based only on the test
example and not based on the training
set
okay okay thank you
yes i'm just trying to reconcile this
with homework one where we were asked
not to like shuffle the examples right
so we the the input to the lstm for a
two short uh problem look like zero one
two three zero one two three or
something like that
so
is that why we were expecting a lower
performance than what we would have uh
when we compared it to second yet or
sorry so to clarify in homework one you
were still shuffling the assignment of
labels to classes because you would
basically randomly sample
n classes and randomly assign end labels
to those classes what you weren't
shuffling was necessarily the kind of
the order in which you passed these
examples into the network
so basically the labels here would be
shuffled and you'd have different
assignments for different classes but
once you
set once you determine that assignment
of
labels to classes for that task then you
fix the order of
the
um
you fix the order of examples uh that
you pass
in okay
um and there's also a question a few
questions in the chat
so
um
it's asking but it should always predict
four for piano and get a high accuracy
right so
it's worth mentioning that
when this happens
the model will actually do great in
terms of meta training performance
it will be able to very accurately
predict that the piano is a four that
the
this particular kind of dog is the two
and so forth
where performance will drop is when
you're given new tasks at meta test time
that have new image classes and the
model doesn't know
the assignment
doesn't know what label those new image
classes correspond to
and then there's also a question of in
the chat about do we have a smaller
performance gap under five-way setting
compared to a 20-way setting
um i can't remember exactly i think i
might be showing results later for the
five-way setting
uh and we might see that later in the
lecture
do you have a question
oh sorry i forgot to blow my hand
yeah and i haven't recorded a doubt like
so we are saying that we have fixed our
labels if we have like 10 classes
so we have fixed the labels to like zero
to nine
and now if this uh sample like if we are
doing like the three three short
training and sample like three classes
out of it
so
how like how will that perform
like mapping work because if you have
three classes and like they are four
seven and nine
and all the cross entropy and things
like that gonna work
so i guess one thing that i'll mention
here is that
there are still so in this example you
have five you're doing five way
classification you have more than five
classes total in your mediterranean set
but you're going to be assigning
multiple examples to the same label for
example the label of four is both being
assigned a piano and also being assigned
to carousel and so basically the
classification task now becomes like is
it a piano and a carousel or a carousel
or is it um
some barrels or a singer
or is it this kind of dog or this tank
and so forth um you could also have
something where you basically assign
you have like
n possible labels and possible
metatrading classes and assign a
different label for piano and for
carousel you'll also run into the same
problem there because
you'll still at meta test time you'll
still be giving it kind of new classes
and it won't figure out how to make a
prediction for those classes
and i had another question the last site
very sure like it won't
like know if they see the same image
classes less training
yeah so this basically corresponds like
what it is essentially reverting to is
just a supervised image classifier that
ignores the training examples and just
classifies the test examples and so if
you see the same image classes the same
like if your piano is one of the meta
training classes and you also see pianos
at meta test time then this is fine
because
you'll get good accuracy on things like
pianos the issue is if you see new image
classes during
new image classes than what you saw
during training it won't be able to
figure out what the correct uh label is
for that class
but like here
uh like middle learning does not have
like much
benefit it's almost as similar giving
like normal supervised learning
uh yes
it's there are some nuances there like
maybe you want to classify like maybe
different task corresponding classifying
pianos in like different regions of the
world or something and they look
different
um
but that's yeah in general this is a
setting that you wouldn't want to apply
by learning to
anyway
okay
so
let's look at a couple other examples
where this might come up uh and
potentially convince you that this is
maybe a problem that's a bit more
concerning
so
we haven't really talked about
reinforcement learning yet but say we
have a robot and we want to be able to
trade across a wide range of tasks and
then be able to quickly learn how to do
a new task
and here are some of the training tasks
uh these are actually real training
tasks from this benchmark uh called meta
world
and
different tasks like one task
corresponds to closing each order one
task corresponds to like using a hammer
to hit a nail another task corresponds
to stacking an object
and maybe when you tell for these sets
of tasks you tell it both like this
language description of what you want it
to do
and you also allow it to collect some
data
for that task
and you want to be able to kind of
quickly be able to be able to quickly
learn from a very small amount of data
how to do that task
now
the tricky part is if you give it both
the data and this description it may
just memorize a policy for each of the
maps from each of these descriptions to
the correct actions for that task
and ignores the data and doesn't
actually leverage the data in order to
quickly adapt
then when you give it a new task like
closing a box it doesn't know how to
interpret close box and it previously
was ignoring the data when it was
learned how to solve each of these tasks
so it's stuck it doesn't know how to
do the task and it also doesn't know how
to quickly adapt from data
so this is kind of another potentially
more real problem where
memorization would really
bite in some way
essentially if you tell the robot what
the task goal is then the robot can just
ignore any trial data that you allow it
to use
and then lastly
one more example
of this is say you want to predict the
pose of objects
and
specifically you want to predict the
orientation so you want to predict the
angle at which the object is facing you
and
you have data for different kinds of
objects
for example this this couch is like at
45 degrees here 108 degrees here you
kind of do the standard thing of
separating out
training data sets and test data sets
for each task
now again what the model could learn to
do here is
memorize the canonical orientation for
each of your training objects and use
that to learn a classifier for each of
the test examples and effectively learn
to ignore
all of the training examples
and then when it's given a new object it
doesn't know
what the canonical orientation for that
object is and it does haven't figured
out how to use the training examples to
infer the canonical orientation
so when you're given a chair for example
it isn't able to figure out what the
orientation of that chair is from a
small number of training examples
okay
great so
uh essentially the model can memorize
economical orientation of the training
examples and i'd like to address the
question in the chat which is can this
be considered as some form of
overfitting as the mediterranean meta
test performance will be quite different
and that's kind of exactly right you can
essentially view this as a form of meta
overfitting
and maybe i'll actually skip forward to
one slide to describe that and then
we'll get to what we can do about it in
a minute so
if we kind of compare metal learning and
supervised learning uh we'll refer to
this problem as meta overfitting where
it's essentially memorizing
training functions f
corresponding to each of the meta
training tasks
and this is somewhat analogous to
standard overfitting except in standard
overfitting and supervised learning
you're memorizing the labels for
training data points
um
so you can kind of view it as like a
metal learning analog of standard
overfitting where instead of memorizing
training data points you're memorizing
the training data functions
um
you're essentially memorizing the
functions that solve each of the
training tasks and then when you try to
generalize to a new task that requires a
new function you are able to figure that
out from data
just like how
uh in standard overfitting you're not
able to figure out the labels for new
examples if you simply memorize each of
the labels in your training set
okay
so
now let's talk about a potential
solution to this
so
to kind of recap where we're at uh if
the tasks are mutually exclusive then a
single function
cannot solve all of the tasks uh this
may be due to label shuffling it may be
doing due to hiding some information
from the meta learner but if the tasks
are not mutually exclusive a single
function can solve all of the tasks
and when we're in this situation there's
actually multiple solutions to the meta
learning problem
um
so if we view our meta learner as
something that just that takes it and
put a training data set and a test input
then one solution
is to essentially
memorize information in theta and ignore
the training examples
for example in the post prediction
example it could memorize the
information about the canonical poses of
all of the training objects in theta
and then ignore the training data set
and then another solution is to carry no
information about the canonical pose in
your parameters data and instead infer
that information from the training
examples
and both of these solutions to the meta
training problem will achieve good
accuracy on the meta training set
however only this example will be able
to generalize to new tasks
and it's also worth mentioning that
there isn't just two solutions there
actually
is essentially an entire spectrum of
solutions based on how information flows
so
uh this is kind of one extreme where and
for all the information about the
canonical pose comes from the training
data set this is another extreme where
all of it comes from theta but you may
have kind of a continuous spectrum of
where information is flowing from
whether more of it is flowing from theta
or more of it is falling from the
training data set
okay
now the cool part about this is this
actually suggests a potential solution
which is that if we can control how
information flows
we can encourage it to
essentially
try to put more information gather more
information from the training examples
and less information
in it from theta
okay
so
with that in mind
we'll develop a meta regularization
method to try to mitigate this problem
and a particular one option that we
might do is try to maximize the mutual
information
between the predicted label
and the training data set given your
test example
and if we're maximizing this information
flow this will encourage it to acquire
information from d train
rather than from theta
uh unfortunately at least
in our experiences it was a little bit
difficult to try to actually quantify
and optimize this term
so what we did instead
is we tried to minimize
both the metatrading laws as well as the
information in theta
uh and
this this second term will essentially
be
a regularization term that encourages it
to store less information and theta
so that it
then is encouraged to
but as a byproduct acquiring more
information from d train
uh and there's actually a pretty nice
way to do this so the mediterranean loss
just looks like uh kind of the standard
meta training losses that we've been
looking at before
and then there's a way to
minimize a bound on the information and
theta by essentially placing
a distribution
on our weights theta so we're going to
have a distribution with mean
theta mu and variance theta sigma and
we're going to
basically minimize the kl divergence
between
this distribution on our weights and
some
prior distribution
and specifically what this corresponds
to is basically just adding noise to our
weights
so instead of having
a
kind of deterministic weight vector
we're going to add noise according to
the variance here
and encourage that noise to not go to
zero by enforcing this prior uh and then
the the kind of noisy weights that are
sampled from this distribution will be
used in our meta training loss
now of course if you only have the meta
training loss then you wouldn't and you
only had this term then they would
choose to store no information or
minimal amount of information in your
weights so it is really a regularization
term that's trying to encourage it to
lead to this solution rather than the
solution that ignores the training
examples
okay
so kind of
in essence this places precedence on
using information from the training
example
over storing information in theta
uh and if you're interested in learning
more about kind of how this is abound
on
information and theta you can look at
some work by uh alex alemi as an example
uh
so
let me at all i think he has a paper
maybe from a few years ago that looks at
basically how
um
how this is a bound on on information
and data
and uh has some kind of description
about how you can optimize this
okay and then it's asking is there a
common choice for the prior over theta
maybe standard normal um yeah that's
right so typically
the kind of most common choice for p of
theta is just a standard normal gaussian
distribution with mean zero and variance
one
uh and the reason why this is really
easy to optimize is that you can
actually
write down the kl divergence for two
gaussians in closed form as a function
of the mean and the variance
which makes it pretty easy to optimize
this
um and then
i guess there's
there's other things that we'll actually
cover next lecture that also make this
easier to optimize
um that essentially allow you to
differentiate through the samples from a
gaussian
but we won't get in that get into that
today
okay do you have a question
yeah i have a question like from what i
understand like memorization makes like
the zero shot performance on the
training data will be quite high
if it has a network has memorized a lot
yeah exactly so if it's memorized a lot
then the zero shot performance will be
great
um
for the training classes
so can we not just like uh make a loss
and maximize this class because we know
ex explicitly we don't want the
performance to be high
yeah so that's a that's actually a
reasonable idea and i think that there's
a paper that maybe tried to do this um
where you basically try to
have minim minimal
pre-update performance uh zero shot
performance and
great
post-update q shot performance
the tricky part is that um
it turns out that the model can actually
still
uh achieve this while also memorizing
basically the um
even if it memorizes the canonical pose
information in theta
the
um it may not it may distort in a way
that isn't accessible or it may just
kind of shuffle the last part the last
layer of the network or something in
some way
such that it kind of
it looks like it isn't memorizing but it
actually is
uh it's maybe
i'm not sure if that was the best
explanation
but essentially the even if the kind of
pre-update performance looks really
terrible that doesn't mean that it isn't
memorizing the information in the
network it could just be that it's kind
of disguising that information and then
exposing it after a gradient update or
after
um
or after you're actually giving it test
examples
okay uh just asking is this kl term more
like a bayesian method where we are
learning a distribution over theta um
yep that's exactly right so another
another method another name for this is
base by backdrop i think i feel like
there's a lot of different names for
this
whoops
and
uh it's actually a common it's worth
mentioning this is actually a common
approach for regularization
regularization on neural networks in
general
um
although in general it hasn't been that
popular for regularizing neural networks
for supervised learning
yeah i want to ask by assuming a prior
and using the scale divergence loss
to make sure that weights follow this
particular distribution how are we
making sure that it's not going to
memorize
it can still memorize uh information
right even if it follows that same
distribution
so it makes it harder to memorize
information or makes it it discourages
it from from memorizing information
because you're basically adding noise to
the weights and then using the the
basically weight sampled from this
distribution overweights when making
predictions um because you're adding
noise that makes it harder to store
information um
in the weights and be as you make it
harder to store information that is
encouraging it to
use information
from other means if possible
and we'll implicitly encourage it to use
information from the training examples
instead
it's worth mentioning that like
part of the reason why well i'll get
into how this how well this works on the
next slide but part of the reason why we
might expect this to work is that both
of these two solutions achieve a very
good meta training loss
and we're simply just trying to tip the
balance towards
this
ladder solution
rather than kind of completely changing
what it does
and so we really only need a fairly weak
regularization term to try to tip the
balance towards the solution and it
turns out that things like adding noise
to the weights
to decrease the amount of information
theta is enough to tip that balance
towards this latter solution
okay um and then it's asking is the
theta here the the pre-update or the
post update so theta is either the
pre-update weights in mammal or they are
the the meta parameters in a black box
you know black box metal learning model
okay um
and then it's also worth mentioning that
you can combine this with your favorite
metal learning algorithm uh
you can combine it both with black box
methods and with
optimization based methods
so i'll just quickly go over the results
and then i'll answer a few more
questions so
for for non-mutually exclusive omni lot
which is basically omniglot where
you have a consistent assignment of
labels to classes again we see that
mammals is quite poorly
there's this other method called
task agnostic metal learning for fuchsia
learning that actually does something
similar to what was suggested before
uh where you encourage the pre-update
weights of mammal to i believe they're
encouraging it to have high entropy
which would implicitly be low
performance
um this also doesn't perform well it's
essentially able to disguise the fact
that it's metal that it's memorizing
whereas if you apply this meta
regularization to mammal and
specifically apply the metabolization on
the weights then you see a really
dramatic change in the performance
because you're able to because it's
essentially tipping the balance towards
the solution that's actually using the
training examples
um and then on the post-production test
that i mentioned also we see
um
we see also kind of a pretty big
improvement in terms of mean squared
error from 5.39 to 2.26
also if you combine the meta
regularization to conditional neural
processes which is a kind of black box
my learner
you also see a pretty big improvement in
performance
um it's also not quite as simple as
standard regularization so if you apply
just like weight decay or base by
backprop to conditional neural processes
um so basically all like
all of the weights in the model not just
the ones that are correspond to the meta
parameters then you don't see as big of
an improvement compared to the um the
metabolization that i just described
okay um do you have a question
sorry uh i wanted to ask this uh drop
out how to make metal overfitting
because like it's also adding noise to
your parameters
yeah so dropout is actually adding noise
to the activations not to the parameters
themselves
uh if you actually look at this paper
metal learning without memorization
there are experiments where you add
noise to the activations in the form of
an information bottleneck rather than
adding noise to the weights
and that performs well in some cases but
not in all cases
and there's an explanation in the paper
for why we might expect adding noise on
the weights to work better
yes so when when when you say that this
data contains information
it is possible for
uh for us to predict some of the tasks
results based on this data value
can we try a network
to do the task
so you're asking
can you predict
the performance from the weights of the
network or something else yes yes from
the waste because you you mentioned that
this data might contain some information
so
barely from this sitter
we might be able to
memorize something and we we might be
able to perform the task
from this database
uh
let's see so you're saying that
you're saying that you you want to
predict basically from from the mean of
the parameters or the variance
uh no no no not for this chao divergence
term so uh
yeah so you so this is a kind of problem
of metal overfitting so
you mentioned that this data may uh
store some information
and i'm just yeah yeah i see i see ac i
do what you're asking yeah so you could
basically try to understand if the
information about the canonical poses
and theta um maybe by like training a
model to predict the canonical poses
from theta or something like that
uh that's a good question so i think
that in the general case you may not
necessarily know
um
know what the kind of thing that will
memorize is like the canonical pose
although in some cases you might
uh i think you could potentially try to
train a model to predict canonical pose
and then you could
like use an adversarial objective to
encourage it not to be able to contain
that specific
amount of information yeah that could be
a reasonable
approach and you could potentially also
do this on on the activations rather
than the weights or both
um
we haven't experimented with that
explicitly
but it seems like a pretty reasonable
reasonable approach
for a
reasonable thing to investigate
yeah thank you
yeah so i was thinking about data
augmentation um that during beta
training um if you
were to add random noise or adversarial
noise to the dust distribution
um i mean would that um help solve this
problem because now we are forcing it to
to look at the data um and and not not
memorized
yeah so there is actually a paper a very
recent paper that i think uh
came out on archive i think it's going
to be at nerfs this year um on trying to
use data augmentation to mitigate this
memorization problem um
and so i'd refer you to that paper
if you're kind of interested in in
looking into that
but
kind of the short story is that they
were able to get pretty promising
results uh by using different forms of
data augmentation to solve the problem
okay and then there are a couple of
questions in the chat that i want to try
to get to so he's asking can you
elaborate on what theta mean and theta
variance is are they the mean and
variance of all dimensions of theta
uh yep so that's correct so they're um
well they're they're basically the mean
and variance of the meta parameters
they are quite high dimensional if theta
is high dimensional
in principle you could potentially apply
them to only a subset of the meta
parameters and i think that actually in
the manual results that i showed uh we
found it most effective to apply the
most predominantly to the encoder
of the network um
to encourage the later layers to still
adapt with data
uh
yeah but the kind of the
you can think of them essentially as uh
as having the dimensionality of the
parameters and being a fixed factor
one for the mean and one fixed vector
for the variance
um asking is there a concept of dropout
for the stages of metal learning it
sounds like applying gaussian noise
would be equivalent to that um
i'm not i think dropout would be
probably a little bit trickier
to implement because
um well it may be a little bit trickier
because once you drop when you drop out
a weight value to zero uh
it may be difficult for the network to
compensate for that uh
but i'm not sure i haven't thought about
that too much when you have noise though
it's a little bit easier to
differentiate through
and then asking does uh applying meta
regularization to shuffled omniglot
improve performance compared to the
non-regularized omniglot
uh so if you're in the kind of standard
omniglot setting and you apply this
i think that it leads to roughly similar
performance maybe slightly better
performance uh empirically
okay uh for the sake of
time i'm gonna keep on going because i
think that we should try to get to
the
the second part
um
i don't really i don't think i have time
to go over this this slide but just one
quick thing worth mentioning is that you
can actually theoretically analyze
this approach uh and kind of actually
derive a bound a generalization bound uh
on the performance that basically looks
something like the error on the
mediterranean set plus the meta
regularization
uh and so this allows you to actually
recover the meta-regularized objective
from this uh pac-maze bound is what it's
called
uh if you're interested in that i'll let
you look at the slides or look at the
paper offline
uh and then to summarize
the memorization problem
we already talked about how
it is essentially analogous it's kind of
a
meta learning analog of standard
overfitting whereas instead of
memorizing the training data points
you're memorizing the training functions
for each of the tasks
and the solution to it or at least one
solution to it there are potentially
other solutions that could maybe be even
more effective
is to control information flow
and
this is in contrast to
standard regularization in supervised
learning where you try to regularize the
hypothesis class
um
metabolization can also be viewed as
trying to regularize the description
length of the meta parameters
um which is somewhat analogous to
regularizing the hypothesis class
um although it's worth noting in
practice that uh things like bayesian
regularization and placing a
distribution over the parameters hasn't
been nearly as successful in supervised
learning as the results that i showed
previously when you have the
memorization problem in middle learning
okay
so now let's talk a bit about metal
learning when you don't have tasks
provided
so we talked a bit about how tasks can
come from different sources
depending on the application domain that
you're in
but in a lot of application areas we may
not even have
data from other
tasks or data from other domains that
may allow us to help solve the problem
so what i want to talk about for the
rest of the lecture is what if we only
have unlabeled data
can essentially the algorithm propose
tasks itself
from unlabeled data
that allows it to
adapt
to new tasks
at meta test time
in particular our goal will be to do
future metal learning from unlabeled
images or unlabeled text
so that we can then actually be able to
solve fut image classification problems
or a few shot text classification
problems
that are defined by a human at meta test
time
so kind of the the problem set up will
be
during
during meta training we'll just have
basically like
a bunch of like
unlabeled data
and then
at meta test time
we will have a
training data set um that's labeled
and
also some test inputs that we want to
make predictions for
so meta test time will look identical to
what we had before what's different is
that during metatrading time we just
have unlabeled data and we need to be
able to construct tasks from that
unlabeled data that will prepare us for
what happens at meta test time
okay
so
first kind of a general recipe for what
this class of approaches have typically
done
is first given some unlabeled data you
want to propose tasks from that
unlabeled data and once you propose
tasks from that you can then run metal
learning on those tasks
so pretty simple right
uh obviously the hard part is is the
task proposing part
and that's what we'll talk about
primarily on the next slides
and so really the goal of unsupervised
learning methods are to automatically
construct tasks from the unlabeled data
okay so i have another question
for all of you
which is
if you were to propose tasks from
unlabeled data
what do you want that distribution over
tasks to look like
i do have any thoughts on
on how you might try to propose tasks in
a way that prepares you
for the tasks that you might see it by
the test time
have a gaussian distribution
a gaussian distribution so what do you
mean by a gaussian distribution
unevenly distributed with a mean um at
which so let's say we have a mean at
which we have a task and then there's
some variants and tasks at each variance
yeah so in evenly distribution like
that's that seems like a reasonable
suggestion i'm not
i'm not sure how to specify a gaussian
distribution over tasks if the task is
well
yeah that seems very reasonable
um do you have thoughts on like what the
mean and variance of that gaussian
distribution would be
um no
okay cool um
that's a good start do uh
do you have thoughts yeah it seems like
proposing task is almost like selective
coming up with labels for the unlabeled
data set in such a way that you you want
to get the labels that help you
learn the tests matter
as good as possible so you kind of want
to come up with labels
that are most similar to your test task
uh
if that makes sense
yeah so
if you had a way to come up with labels
for all of your training data set then
one thing you could do is construct kind
of tasks that
are
um
from that kind of labeled data set
similar to how we typically do
and you would want those labels to be
reflective of the kinds of labels that
we might see at test time
so that's a good thought
yeah so for classification problem for
example we could
we could look at the data distribution
in a different space like latent space
or something and we could
cluster
different distribution and each could
correspond to a different class
something like
that yeah so we could basically try to
have different
different kinds of tasks potentially is
that what you're suggesting
yeah
cool uh
other thoughts from
so we might want to find like a diverse
set of tasks that sort of like uh cover
the whole like data set
so it's not like partitioning but um
have each set start like tasks be as
serious as possible but each task
internally contains like uh examples of
uh that are very similar to each other
yeah so this is also similar i think to
what maybe was suggesting is that it
seems like we probably want to use all
of our all of our data set and and
somewhat evenly use our data set rather
than kind of focusing on different parts
of the data set
or skewing our our distribution in some
way
um there are also some suggestions in
the chat such as using self supervision
to propose tasks and to partition the
unlabeled data into clean clusters
maybe where different clusters are
different tasks
so
thinking about this problem
the two things that i came up with for
the slides is
uh
diversity in tasks and i think this is
kind of
what what you all meant by trying to
have more evenly distributed tasks
essentially if you have more evenly
distributed tasks or more diverse tasks
you're more likely to cover the test
task so the test test is more likely to
be in that set of tasks if you have a
diverse set of tasks
now with this extreme though if you have
too diverse of a set of tasks
then you may not be able to actually you
may not your middle learner may not
actually be able to pick up on
any structure in that set of tasks and
so you also need your tasks to be
structured so that fused metal learning
is even possible
um for example at the extreme where you
just sample completely random tasks from
your data
there won't be any structure to pick up
on
in order to learn efficiently with a
small number of examples
and so we're going to try to aim for
both diverse tasks and structured tests
okay so we'll talk first about how you
might construct tasks from unlabeled
image data and then we'll talk about
constructing tasks from text data
so first let's talk about labeling from
unlabeled or metal learning from
unlabeled images and the approach here
is actually going to be quite similar
to the approach suggested in the chat
which is the partition unlabeled data
indicating clusters
and in particular what we're going to do
is
we're first going to run an unsupervised
learning algorithm to get some embedding
space
this is because working in the original
image image space is quite challenging
so this will allow us to embed images in
our training example in our in our meta
training set
to a lower dimensional embedding space
shown here
i
visualized in 2d for for ease of
visualization
and then what we'll do is we'll run
clustering in this latent space just
using k-means clustering
and we'll propose tasks as
classification tasks of classifying
between images in different
clusters and so concretely what this can
look like is we'll we'll cluster
actually multiple times so one
clustering one run of k means clustering
may give us something like this another
run may give us something like this
and then
to construct a task we'll sample two
clusters maybe the red cluster in the
blue cluster and the task will be to
classify
images from one cluster versus images in
another cluster
so we'll construct our training data set
as these two examples right here and
we'll construct our test example as
these two
uh images right here
so this will give us a kind of a two-way
one-shot classification task
and we can then construct another task
for example maybe by looking at this
purple cluster versus the screen cluster
and we can also uh construct n-way
classification tasks by sampling n
disjoint clusters
and then of course once we have these
tasks of discriminating between
different clusters we can then run
our favorite metal learning algorithm
okay and the result of this is kind of a
representation that's suitable
for really quickly learning downstream
tasks because you're training it to be
able to distinguish between different
clusters
given a small
data set
okay so this is kind of the first
approach um
how do you get the the embedding space
uh for this you can use kind of existing
unsupervised representation learning
methods out of the box
uh like bygan or deep cluster there are
also more recent approaches than this as
well
uh w1k means clustering and proposed
cluster discrimination tasks uh we refer
to this method as clustering to
automatically construct tasks for
unsupervised med learning or cactus uh
and then we run
metal learning on top of uh on top of
those tasks
uh so if you're interested in what a
mammal on top of a cactus looks like you
get something like this
and uh if you look at mini imagenet
uh if you run mammal with kind of full
labels on the meta training set you get
62 accuracy
if you compare to
different approaches of learning on top
of the initial representation space
you get lower accuracy but you still do
somewhat reasonably
um if you run
mammal on top of the
clustered tasks you get five shot
accuracy around 51
and if you use actually the deep cluster
latent space instead you get 50 almost
54 accuracy
on
five way five shop in the imagenet
um and this is without any labels in the
meta training set just using the
unlabeled images in the mini imagenet
metatrading set
uh so this is pretty cool we can
actually start to approach the
performance of a fully
supervised metal learning algorithm
and
you really see kind of the same trend of
results for four different embedding
methods for data sets other than mini
imagenet like omniglot slab a and mnist
also for prototypical networks and for
test tasks that have larger data sets
that are larger than five shot for
example
okay so that's kind of the first
approach that we can take um now another
thing worth considering is maybe in some
domains we have some knowledge about
what might make a good task
um so for example in the realm of image
classification we know that if we do
certain certain things with the image
the label won't change
so if you drop out some of the pixels or
you translate the image a little bit or
if you reflect the image
from left to right
then typically the label of that image
won't change
for example
if you take this omni lot digit and
translate it a little bit and drop out
some of the pixels
it still has the same identity
likewise if you take an image from mini
imagenet and you reflect it left right
then
this image still has the same class as
the image before
and so we can use this domain knowledge
to
develop a way to propose tasks
by simply
using augmented versions of our examples
as additional examples from that class
uh so in particular what this looks like
is for each task that we want to
construct we randomly sample n images
and assign the labels one to n
so for example maybe we sample these
three images and assign them
corresponding labels
and then for each of these data points
we augment the image using our domain
knowledge
and assign them the same corresponding
labels
and this top row can correspond to the
training data set for that example
and the bottom row can correspond to the
test set
so we're basically kind of using our
domain knowledge about how
how examples
about intra class variation within a
class
and using that to construct new examples
about how the model should be able to
generalize after training on
these examples
okay so this is another way to construct
tasks
and again you can also once you
construct tasks using your unlabeled
data set you can then apply this with a
metal learning algorithm
it's worth mentioning that every once in
a while you will sample images that have
the same underlying class
uh and
in practice that's often uh
that's often okay uh it will give you
kind of more
diverse tasks and some of the tasks that
you're giving your metal earner won't
reflect the kinds of tasks you see at
meta test time
what's most important is that the meta
test task is kind of within the convex
hall of the tasks that you're training
on
uh
asking is this similar to
self-supervised learning uh yes so
this sort of data augmentation has also
been pretty successful in the realm of
self-supervised learning as well
uh and so if you take this approach um
and for omniglot use translation and
pixel drop out for augmentation and for
mini imagenet you use a mixture of
translation rotation and shear based on
this kind of auto augment approach in
the paper by cubic at all
um we see results that look like this
uh to summarize there's really
outstanding omni lot performance
uh the performance actually almost
approaches
the fully supervised performance so in
the five-way five-shot setting
it's like 95 versus 98 percent
on the 20-way five-shot setting it's 92
versus 96.
um this is because in omniglot we have
pretty good domain knowledge about these
about the images in omniglot
uh and the mini image that the
performance is kind of slightly below
that of cactus this is probably because
we don't have quite as good domain
knowledge about all of the kinds of
variation that natural images have
within the class
and it's hard to construct forms of
augmentation that cover all of that
intraclass variation
okay
um
do you have a question
uh yeah
do you think you can go back to
the first um slide with the title can we
learn can we meddle in with only online
little images
yeah
so
um i'm not sure if i'm interpreting this
the wrong way but
it seems like
this is just kind of teaching
or it's learning how to classify images
that are like visually similar based on
like the test the tasks that are created
um
so how are we supposed to get an image
classification like of say like
classifying a fruit as a fruit versus
like a jellyfish such a jellyfish out of
this
yeah so
i guess it's worth mentioning that um
the goal of this kind of approach isn't
to get a classifier out of it the goal
is to be able to
do few shot classification at test time
and so these tasks don't have to be
perfect um and they don't have to
like perfectly match all the tasks
you're going to be seeing at meta test
time you simply want to cover a pretty
diverse range of tasks that you might
potentially see at meta test time
and um
and
if it kind of learns to generally kind
of distinguish things
i distinguish kind of a diverse range of
things then maybe from a small amount of
examples of those things then at test
time it may be able to also distinguish
things
in the meta test
in the meta test tasks based on a small
number of examples for your meta test
task
so at test time sorry go ahead oh go
ahead
um so at test time would we be giving
examples that are all like within the
same class
that like say we would want to classify
or
would it also be like a wide variety of
things
yeah so at test time maybe you want to
kind of be able to classify between your
two pets or something and so you would
give it like five images of one pet five
images of another pet and then
adapt the model that was meditated on
these examples to
your classification problem
exactly thanks
it's also worth mentioning that this
kind of this approach is probably by no
means perfect and there's probably a lot
that we could do to improve upon this
it's also very challenging to kind of in
a completely unsupervised way
distinguish different classes
um i think that the power of the power
of this though is that these tasks don't
necessarily need to exactly correspond
to
true semantically meaningful tasks
as long as you have essentially a means
to cover a broad range of structured
tasks
yeah so testing so these proposed tasks
are designed to help to train the image
encoder which will be used at test time
so these tests will be used to train
kind of a my learning algorithm such as
in a set of initial parameters with
mammal
and then at test time you want to run
gradient descent or run your kind of
or run prototypical networks or
something
on a small data set and be able to
transfer
to that
that new task
um yeah so i was just wondering so if i
understand it correctly the cactus
approach which was the clustering is
like an alternative to the one where you
are incorporating domain knowledge right
like there's two different approaches
yeah right so in case of you just don't
incorporate any domain knowledge and you
used to unsurprise clustering define
tasks but in this i guess um pra you
call it
um you just
like augment existing data like images
and use that as your test form um if
that's the case then in this umtra case
what happens if you
let's say sampled like
three
or four like dog same brain dog images
in your end
wouldn't they be
then considered as like distinct classes
yeah so that's kind of one of the
failure modes of this kind of umtra
approach
is that with some probability you will
be sampling classes images from the same
class
luckily if you have a large number of
classes in your mediterranean set that
will be that will happen with relatively
low probability
um and again even if some of your tasks
aren't representative of the kinds of
things that you see at meta test time
that's kind of okay as long as the
the kind of the large the predominantly
the predominant part of your
mediterranean tasks that are proposed by
the algorithm do cover
the the meta test tasks
um but this is kind of a kind of a
downside of this approach
cool thanks
okay um and now let's briefly talk about
metal learning with only unlabeled text
so the first option here is a formulated
as a language modeling problem
this is an example like this is what we
saw when we looked at gpt3 for example
where d train is a sequence of
characters detest is the following
sequence of characters and we saw with
that how basically you can use a lot of
unlabeled text data to train a model
such that it can learn things like
simple math problems spelling correction
and translating between languages
uh so this is one uh one successful
approach for using only unlabeled data
um
we might we not want to use this option
so
i think that this sort of option is a
bit harder to combine with optimization
based metal learning because you'd have
to somehow
adapt your model with gradient descent
on
the
unlabeled text that you're given
uh and i also think that it may be
harder to apply the classification tasks
um because it's the model is just
outputting kind of
text
rather than classification labels such
as labels for sentiment classification
or political bias
and so it's
i think that you could apply it to
classification tasks with a bit of work
but it's probably a bit harder to do
because you have to process the natural
language output that it produces
okay so
another option that was actually
recently proposed by bon salado
and actually i think came up on archive
within the past month or two
uh is to construct tasks by masking out
words
so
uh different tasks will basically
correspond to classifying the word that
was masked out and trying to figure out
what that word was
specifically what this looks like is for
each task you can sample a subset of n
unique words
assign each of those
unique words a different label id
so for example maybe you sample two
words democratic and capital
you assign them the id of one and two or
the label of one and two
and then you sample
sentences with each of those words
masking out that word
and construct the training set in the
test set with the max the math sentences
and the corresponding word ids as the
label
so as a concrete example your support
set might look like this
where this is kind of democratic and
capital again
and the
word that was selected is masked out and
the model needs to predict
which
word
was masked out
so this has kind of kind of both inputs
and labels
and then the test data set
corresponds to a new sentence with that
word masked out and the corresponding
label
this is a pretty simple way to construct
a large number of classification
tasks from
text
and uh it works pretty well so
they can have actually a lot of results
everything to the left of this bar is
kind of using an entirely unsupervised
pre-training approach
and then everything on the right also
incorporates some supervised tasks
if we first look at the entirely
unsupervised
pre-training results burt is like a
standard self-supervised approach where
you um it's actually quite similar to
the masked uh
to the method proposed here
um whereas smlmt is the proposed
unsupervised metal learning algorithm
that we just went over
and so we see that in general these
approaches tend to perform pretty
similarly except for perhaps on the
disaster data set where
the unsupervised metal learning approach
does a lot better
and then in this more supervised setting
they compared to multitask learning
approaches where you train on a number
of supervised learning tests and then
fine-tune a new task
they also compare to leopard which is an
optimization based metal earner based on
mammal where this is trained also only
on the supervised tasks
and then they compared to their hybrid
method which does unsupervised metal
learning on their proposed tasks but
also integrates the supervised learning
tasks into the meta learner
and overall they find that the this
metal learning approach that kind of
incorporates both unsupervised metal
learning tasks and supervised metal
learning tasks is able to do
significantly better than these other
approaches that don't leverage the
unsupervised tests or um don't leverage
the supervised tests
okay
um so we're running out of time so we'll
skip this last part um
and then yeah to recap we talked about
memorization we talked about different
ways to propose tasks from unlabeled
data uh this gives us a class of
unsupervised meta-learning algorithms
um and
yeah covered the goals of of trying to
talk about how and when memorization
will occur and also techniques for
constructing tasks
uh i have a question regarding this uh
language classification taskers flu shot
determining the class using us like
sampling different words and masking
them so do you think it would matter
like
uh if the classification task can be
made harder like in the sense instead of
sampling words like democratic and
capital let's say the sample words like
democratic and republic
and because those two words can fill the
context but the model need to know some
other knowledge
as well to find out whether the
democratic word would be the
best choice for the republic word
yeah that's it that's a great idea i
think that if you completely randomly
sample words then you'll probably get
words that are
very easy to distinguish between um like
if you sampled for example between like
democratic and like
with or
rival or something um
or even like words that are like nouns
versus adjectives as in this example too
um so yeah i think that some sort of way
to
encourage them the method to find harder
pairs of words and harder sets of words
would be would probably actually lead to
better performance from these methods
okay
yeah
one more note on that is you may also
want to make it not too hard so if for
example
the two words that you pick are like
purple and blue and there are many
situations where
you can't necessarily distinguish when
like maybe like she has a purple water
ball or a blue water bottle you can't
really know which one is the right color
um then you're going to be giving it
tasks that are impossible and that may
lead to overfitting and worse
performance so there's a bit of a
balance just right there
so yeah so just to follow up on that so
would you consider this to be a like a
possible project exploration idea for
this class yeah i think that that would
be a great a great direction for a
project okay thank you
hi um i had a quick question about uh
the lost plus beta information flow uh
the slide that you had that
uh yeah
um i'm curious the beta itself if you
tried decaying it and not keeping it
constant what would happen
yeah so beta is a hyper parameter here
that is actually pretty important
because you need to make sure that it's
like strong enough but also not not zero
um
it could make sense to decay it if it's
having trouble finding a good solution
to this problem so for example you may
want to start it as being high and then
decay it
to be lower
and if you start as high basically it
will encourage it to really
use anything that it can and d train and
then if you kind of decreased over time
then they can store more information in
theta
um so that that seems like it could be a
reasonable approach especially if
finding like a single value of beta is
hard
okay thank you
i had a question about i think your
final slide with all the results um and
because in that slide it says like only
for the disaster task the unsupervised
learning works better so is there any
like specific characteristics
and is there like any reasoning why just
for that specific task unsupervised for
experiment supervised because
the intuition i think is that supervised
is always better because you just use
more information right or is it not sure
yeah so first it's worth mentioning that
you also see an improvement on the
political bias task when you have a
larger number of shots and also
i actually cut off this table there's
actually more data sets that they tested
on too i just couldn't fit it on the
slide um and i think that there were
also some more where the unsupervised
method was doing better
i don't quite understand why
um why the fully unsupervised method is
doing better in this case than the one
that incorporates supervised tasks my
intuition would that would be that like
incorporating supervised house should
always help
um
it's possible that that maybe they have
an explanation in the paper uh i didn't
see it when i went over the paper but i
may have missed it
i guess one thing that i could mention
is that maybe i can't remember exactly
what supervised tasks that they were
using to incorporate into metatrading
that maybe those tasks were quite
different from the kinds of tasks that
you see
in this test task uh and maybe the
unsupervised tasks are just a little bit
closer to the kinds of tasks that you
see
um
at test time
right but then it might also be harder
to get right unsupervised
all right yeah yeah
yeah okay
hi um i have a question on the slide 16.
so where you have all the um sofa and
objects and angles yeah
so um so for this type of task the
labels is the angled object right and
for the model to infer from what's the
angle is the task test set
it needs to know the relationship
between labels
instead of like regular classification
tests each level is independent so how
does the model learn that from from
yeah so it needs it you need to kind of
more than well
i guess
it does need to i kind of understand
like
if uh
yeah if for you need to kind of look at
two images either like two of the images
in your training example or one image
here and one image here to be able to
kind of compare the orientations
um
the
methods like protocol that works like
already build this in to some degree
because you're kind of comparing them
although it's also a regression task so
it'd be a bit tricky to apply things
like protocol that works to it
um
in general though
like models like black box models and
mammal do incorporate information from
multiple examples
mammal does it by averaging the gradient
and then black box models do it by
processing all of the examples of input
and so they have the capacity to
to look at kind of multiple examples
jointly
to some degree
and that that's kind of
one way that allows them to solve this
task does that answer your question
um wait so you're saying this is a
regression test instead of
way classification
uh we treated it as a regression task
you could also treat it as a 360 way
classification task
okay
um so do you also apply
another question would be on do you also
apply a uniform
or a global
angle measurement across different
images because you can define the angle
so it depends on where how do you how
you
aim your axis right yeah so that's kind
of what i meant by the canonical
orientation that's kind of like the the
base axis
however it's
with different object shapes it's hard
to determine like basically each object
has to have its own canonical
orientation
it's difficult to align
objects
in a way that allows you to have the
same canonical orientation for each for
all the objects
thank you
method where you can sample multiple
classes but if you like music
start as much as like first class tell
them and then always select from
different clusters maintain
that and
and that is
constructed from the training set so you
won't be much biased by the
issues that the clustering method might
have
yeah so i don't know of any methods that
combine them um one kind of naive way to
combine them would just be to train on
both tasks both sets of tasks
but there may be more interesting
sophisticated ways to to try to combine
them as well
and then one question i have regarding
the last step in the
text classification
pain so burton's a really strong
baseline here and it does perform pretty
well although i will say that kind of
even though the performance is like you
see only a small improvement in some
cases like from 49 to 52
there are other settings where you see a
much larger improvement
um for example from like 42 to 56 that's
kind of a 14 absolute improvement or
like 38 to 63 um
or yeah there are kind of other examples
as well so like 54 to 61. there there
are examples where you see a pretty big
improvement 50 to 70 is another
um
but yeah it is burt is a is a pretty
strong
baseline and has also been kind of
heavily